me and my cell battery's about to die I
gotta go charge it batteries don't lose
charge welcome to the science asylum I
am Nick lucid I've got a pet peeve a lot
of language we use to describe
electronics is terrible not only is it
just plain wrong it also makes it more
difficult for people to learn the truth
you've got this preconceived notion and
it needs a fixin so if it doesn't lose
charge what does it lose energy energy
is the ability or capacity to do work
basically it measures a things ability
to do stuff the earth gives this blue
and the ability to fall sunlight gives
this flower the ability to grow and my
breakfast gave me the ability to do this
energy is about doing stuff and that's
exactly what you want your phone to do
stuff wait so then what's charge charges
are those things in your phone that do
stuff did you know that if you push your
phone in the right places a pizza will
arrive at your house we live in an
amazing time anyway charges are what
make up atoms so everything has charges
in it you need this phone even this
battery the second closer look at this
thing here's a typical alkaline battery
with a positive and negative end
basically triple A's double-a C's DS etc
inside there are two metals zinc
connected to the negative end and
manganese dioxide connected to the
positive end they're separated by a thin
insulator made of potassium hydroxide
and water which prevents any chemical
reactions from happening on their own I
mean we don't want to dying on us just
sitting in a bin even though a battery
like this has a voltage labeled on it it
doesn't actually have that until you
bring extra electrons to the party where
do we get those extra electrons from
your device all these things are just
chock-full of electrons and conductors
like metals let those electrons move
around let's see what happens when we
connect something to the battery will
keep things simple and just connect the
copper wire that wire like your phone is
already full of electrons we just need
to make them move and that's what the
battery is for the moment you connect
the wire the positive end gobbles up
electrons the reaction creates hydroxide
ions that drift into the separating
layer that layer absorbs them it pops
off more on the office
sigh which starts a reaction on the
negative end of the battery this new
reaction releases electrons into the
other end of the wire now that the
chemistry is in full swing the battery
has an energy difference between the two
ends and it will keep things moving
until you disconnect it or it dies the
weird thing about that electrons never
flow through the battery on their own so
how does the battery die doesn't it run
out of charge no it runs out of
reactants on the positive end manganese
dioxide is slowly turned into mega news
3 oxide I hate nomenclature on the
negative side zinc is slowly turned into
zinc oxide new oxidation once it runs
too low on one of those it's dead
no coming back but the battery in my
phone isn't that kind of battery its
rechargeable the battery in your phone
is re-energized Abul so it's just made a
different things why don't we take a
closer look at one of those the positive
end is lithium cobalt oxide the negative
end is graphite and again they're
separated by a thin insulator at the
moment the battery can provide any
energy it's dead when you connect your
charger energy comes from the wall
socket and the positive end of the
battery releases lithium ions and
electrons the electrons go into the
charger and get lost in the abyss of the
wires the lithium ions dripped across
the battery to the negative end where
they attach to the graphite the battery
is full when you've moved all the
lithium you can as the phone uses the
battery's energy the whole thing happens
in Reverse until you've moved all the
lithium back to the positive end
the point is batteries always have the
same amount of charge they just don't
always have the same amount of energy
we're guys so what's the worst place
you've ever been when your battery died
please share in the comments and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy